it's the same thing with video games
like men that will play video games are
going to be more violent because I'm
pretty sure the evidence was the
opposite with that I I definitely don't
believe it I I think that is true as
well because for example I don't know
about not really in the UK but I heard
about a lot of school shootings with
like young people in America like it's
always to do with guns and always to do
with yeah like those kind of like video
games so I think that definitely has an
impact as well but then that's like
everything has an impact with social
media and with technology because even
what we see online might change the way
that we move or we look so everything
does I think but I think it's only going
to amplify what's already there it's
already there yeah so if you're someone
that's that Way Incline then yeah it
might imply but I think for most people
playing video games as a way to safely
indulge in your fantasies